andalorian baby season 1 episode 6
excited to check this bad boy out man I
rewatched Return of the Jedi this week
so I am at the right point in the
timeline to be watching the Mandalorian
beautiful boba fett day
first and foremost before we swing on
into this YouTube only allows for 10
minutes worth of footage to be included
reaction highlights so the full length
reaction stream alongs are all over at
our patreon page and the person cutting
up the reaction highlights for us is a
man named Eric over at nerd cronic if
you watch the movie trivia Schmo down or
the Sen Network you will have heard his
name mentioned quite a bit cuz he edits
for them he also edits for people like
Eamon snow and aqus on has his own
podcast / podcasts are found Thank You
Eric he really is just a great guy so
thank you so much for doing this buddy
and thank you to everyone who's been
making sure to hit that subscribe button
and clicking that notification belt that
way you can you notified whenever our
next mando reaction is up or YouTube
video let's swing into action here hey
dude Harvey from Batman Begins and
five-person job I got four
is that gratitude hey Phil yeah bill
bird guy was telling you about we used
to do jobs way back when he did some
crazy stuff didn't we that was a long
time ago in a galaxy far far away oh
geez Rick
former imperial sharpshooter former
wasn't a stormtrooper wiseass taking a
jab at this I can't believe that thing
can fly it's like I can't do a bite slot
machine last Jedi I thought you said you
had four
she tell me why I shouldn't cut you down
mr. he nice to see you too it's like
John wick or something yeah I mean it's
not much bigger than it is a great great
set up yeah
joining a job and they're all gonna
betray his ass once they find out yeah
how much he's worth in that child the
board find our friend get him out of
there before they make that jump that's
a New Republic prison ship men wasn't
taken by a rival syndicate
he was arrested I'm not looking for that
kind of heat well neither are we but we
like watching [ __ ] like that
so you better do it someone tell me why
we even need a Mandalorian
well apparently they're the greatest
warriors in the galaxy were they all
dead that's me I flew with them she uh
he never takes off the helmet hey maybe
he's a Gungan ah is that why you still
don't want to show your face I've never
seen his face
Oh God even though he knew this is gonna
have him no unexpected the way did you
to make that oh god do bill burr is
perfect in this yeah baby I'll try again
don't touch [ __ ] oh hey start of a
whole new life nasty nope that's a setup
for disaster right there oh dude don't
make noise yep
[Music]
my man yes oh damn oh yeah yes oh I can
watch him kill Joyce for hours okay oh
no you go hard are with their violence
when their droid oil and gear right
there were only supposed to be droids on
this ship okay look hey put it down you
crazy put it down
we're not here for you we're here for a
prisoner if you let us go about our job
you can walk away with your life
man what oh just shut up no wonder he
broke up with you you should have
followed mandos like the different
renditions on the music in this episode
yeah add to the intensity questions
bilborough's characters really should
have valley believes yes more so he is
like some bacon counter with this race
Oh what you mother
all that Suggs doesn't really fit just
call them [ __ ]
it's calm [ __ ] need one time and they
could make them a one-liner they were
wisecrack use the force curious hey wait
what about your sister
Hey nice family yeah that guy's a jerk
he only cares myself extra jerk a sci-fi
[Music]
always so cute come on to delay too long
now he's known how long he's held boy
yeah damn doors that one please tell me
one of those words this is the best
action of the season so far it's the
best action for sure notice his shot
trailer oh yeah there you go he's good
at something okay he's an imperial
sharpshooter yeah that's right
I am so cool look how love this whoa oh
I guess a heart oh he's the boogie men
[Music]
like 12 minutes six use the Force
oh you're gonna use a force
oh oh I was hoping he had used it yeah I
did the job
one coin please just like the good old
days yeah just like the good old days
shut down his license for you know
something's gonna happen
oh [ __ ]
yeah my man oh damn was that uh uh
Fulani Navy Dave Filoni that's the
director of a three-dollar represented
Chow Deborah I think I think I think
Levi's guys the directors cool Oh
oh I didn't kill any of them I'm glad
they kept them a lot and now they're
just stranded in space it's gonna be I
can't wait for the episode where they're
like trying to get the revenge yeah
oh that's great oh that was great
easily my favorite episode of the season
so far
he likes it yeah I don't know what
anyone's saying about this episode but
that is easily my favorite office yes
omble tan just the tensity I get the
impression that some people get a little
bit up I think it's really in the
minority of people who watch this Clancy
Brown give me annoyed that they're not
like as super Stu realized they would
hope yeah yeah it's very episodic I mean
this it's like a space Westerners show
though listen just back then we're like
episodic kind of like um hasn't kung fu
about this kind of thing where it's just
like a wandering nomadic warrior who
gets around a lot of other people's
situations okay got a classic they got a
through-line here yeah very cool
Twilight's twi'lek I don't how to spell
it how you spelling the Twi then they're
like the weird apostrophe le okay I
think I will actually turn the Jedi
recently you know I was like what are
those creatures called did you google
like tail head yeah girl who dances for
Jabba the Hutt yeah oh yeah that's even
more succinct yeah well they I mean the
creature is also in like they the one of
them's like a a Jedi and like the
prequels and stuff before we hop into
our review for this episode which I
can't wait to talk about I didn't want
to mention that yes our full-length
reaction stream belongs for Mandalorian
it--over
at over are over at our patreon page
over there we do weekly Q&A s and we
actually have TV show reaction stream
logs for many shows those shows are
agents of shield stranger things season
3 awesome and there's some other shows
as well and then of course their shows
were there stream along and reaction
highlights included like how you saw for
this YouTube cut and those shows are
supernatural onto a untuck code geass
Death Note my hero academia movie
included attack on Titan under some
other shows as well go over to our
patreon page if you want to watch more
TV shows along with us or watch the
reaction highlights anyway let's swing
into this for baby that man I just
really love the tension and the mood
every episode has lent itself to a
familiar action story plot line and this
is no exception we've seen this plot
line done before but I said the Deltora
reference it was because I don't know if
it's in the reaction highlights but I
said I kind of get some slight when del
Toro does action movies vibes from it
just with its color scheme there's that
character that's Star Wars creature that
Clancy Brown plays Berg oh yeah and then
I was displayed to kind of has a similar
plot line with blade teaming up with
mercenaries yeah and then you can't
trust that man you know and then also
something with the droid reminding me of
the the character I think Seth
MacFarlane voiced and Hellboy yeah the
first thing I thought oh just having
some of those aesthetics and vibes made
me flash to something like Deltora but
overall I did feel like its own thing I
loved the way it dealt with colors
especially red in this episode - really
I can wait and it felt like I was like
an 80s sci-fi horror movie at that point
especially with those nasty Dutch angles
and so this is shaping into some John
waking advice which I know John wick is
not totally original itself he
especially started giving some boogeyman
vibes oh yeah when he like totally
sneaks up behind bill burr with the
flashing strobe yeah yeah I think the
way they choreographed all the action
here the reason why it's so effective
and so cool is because of the mood
established and the lead into these
action scenes as well write down when
he's like fighting the droids usually
when I see action sequences in the Star
Wars movies when they're fighting droids
I don't really find them that cool and
there's not really any tension to them
they always seem like they're so easy to
defeat I'm just going off of the movies
really did love how when they show up on
the on the prison ship the gang is all
shooting at them and they can't seem to
work around them like mando it's smart
enough to be a little bit stealthy and
the way that fight plays out - or he's
like he is a badass but he's also taking
the hits and it is kind of hard exactly
they did show that there are some droids
that can be very little to deal with I
did enjoy the ensemble of the murse
you know like these episodes are short
they're like serialized episodic s' I do
think that they could have probably done
a little bit more with the gang to make
them feel like threatening or something
like that yeah you know if this episode
was maybe a little longer you could have
thrown in a couple more sinister
character beats or something like that
yeah I'll really demonstrate what makes
this gang of mercy like how they could
have there was a possibility I could
have did like most of the heavy lift the
pilot is really good and I mean he kind
of lives up to that but yeah the rest of
them seem to rely heavily on men I think
what they made up with with lack of
demonstrating skill I enjoyed the
personality that the characters were
given or at least that the actors were
able to bring to it the hint at history
and I feel like that also kind of makes
you flash to like John wick like films
oh the whole hinting at history instead
of showing you and clearly laying out
the history
Xion jian jian jian yeah with their
brother brother as well it's kind of
cool seeing like these different getting
hints at these different sides of mando
obviously Mandalorians procreate but you
never really get with there he'll never
really get the vibe of like you don't
imagine him like dating or having effect
yeah exactly going out you know it's
seven nice dinner together light
romantic moments and so to see like in
the fourth episode like he has romantic
feelings for that one girl here has kind
of like a sexual history with this one
chick hey yeah intentionally and then
you're like is this the kind of society
where everyone's leo yeah we keep our
helmets on but secretly on the down-low
everybody takes it especially if you
have humans under that armor in any
capacity and I'm sure other species too
they're they're gonna want to answer
nature's call one this is like some of
the best choreography I've seen out of
any of the Star Wars movies I would say
that's not involving lightsaber fights
or anything like that the one with the
droids was tactical and smart and didn't
rely on blasters and then the fight that
he has with birds kind of like a
wrestling match in close-quarter
proximity you know this stealthy vibes
that he just provides but instead of
just being a warrior who
justgo was it in their homeland you know
he's really so he's practical and using
all his weapons at his disposal when
necessary that philosophy of not being
dependent on those extra weapons but
only using them when needed yeah and I
think they really hone in on that with
this character and also the way they
they utilize the music it was constantly
like different riffs and renditions and
the mando songs we've heard to really
add to the emotional flavor of the
episodes I think is just wonderful oh
yeah well I and I really just like the
overall character debate there because
especially on the heels of the
documentary we just watched having these
moments where mando has to you're
learning through his actions kind of
what his philosophy is becoming and yeah
I like that that scene in the control
room on the one hand yeah he's
developing sympathy and so you do think
well maybe if this guy doesn't need to
die we don't have to kill him but I also
like that even as a mercenary even as
you know somebody who operates on the
lower ends of the universe you know he
doesn't just kill just because it seems
like he always has the bigger picture in
mind after that contrast made for
something nice because you know the
job's gonna go bad but I did like that
he kind of is at least enforcing you
have this code knowing that this job's
gonna go bad is something that I give
this show a lot of credit for of what
they tend to pull off very well I
thought episode four was the most
predictable one of them all worth like
this one almost exactly like how you'd
imagined it to go the one that felt like
exactly like Magnificent Seven yeah or
uh uh or Seven Samurai something like
that it's like we all felt it right from
the beginning you know these guys are
bad you know they're gonna find baby
Yoda you know they're gonna betray mando
on the ship but you know all these
things are gonna go down yet when they
occurred they managed to make of those
moments surprising and how it went down
yeah you felt the tension especially
cutting back and forth between the
things going to [ __ ] on the ship and
also zero stocking baby Yoda
when mando is first having a dispute
with Berg on the razor crest and then he
hits the bottom by accident and then
baby odors reveal then you're like oh
it's like you know they're gonna find
him at some point this yeah but then
when that happens it's surprising or
when they officially do betray mando and
they immediately swap him out with the
that was done in a moment that you don't
expect so it's like even though you know
these things are going to happen when
they occur it's like some people or like
us are coming and they kind of discredit
it but it's more about how you do it
that I think as long as the effect of
the moment is there that's what counts I
think yeah even the things that were
somewhat predictable had just flavors
and nuances that I appreciated that
seemed very of this show and also man
bill ver I wish we got like sending him
up as like he's an imperial sharpshooter
like that jab at the at the stormtrooper
line I thought I mean you got a jab at
the even in a Jar Jar mission I would
like to have seen more of what made him
like a leader of this and really cool
other than he's got the most appealing a
sense of attitude yeah bill bird he's
like funny and charming and credit to
the guy because I've seen it I think
every one of his recorded stand-up
specials I thought I would have to
really do a lot of work on my own brain
to just believe bill burr in this world
I don't know if it was ultimately
distracting for other people considering
how famous of it is they they put
comedians in this show a lot yeah
horatio sanz was drenched in makeup in
this episode the droid hear Richard III
oh and yeah he comedian as well they
like to put their comedians in this show
bill burr not in makeup not disguised as
anything else he's not a droid versus
Bill burr he's saying lines that are all
Star Wars heavy and and it especially
hit me in the moment when they're having
their little Mexican standoff he's like
get that blaster out of my face and like
sounds like believable what is he feel
like bill birnes the kind of guy who
would make fun of Star Wars fans or
whatever laughing while trying to
memorize these lines to get into
characters something but he's good at
doing it and yeah I feel like it's an
interesting element of casting because
it's like he popped up on Breaking Bad -
and also I but he wasn't the bill burr
he is now you know true but also you
know he still had some stature and even
there he blended in so I think it's a
credit to his abilities as a performer
and and that sort of sneaky quality
because most of us go oh comedian and so
we're kind of set up to be surprised but
I think it also is a credit to people
who cast him because
I thought they cast him well into this
role of this role bei very much feeds
into his strength it's the right blend
of I believed him as this in this role
when he's reusing the guns and stuff
it's not silly but same time two
characters require to be funny I was
pretty excited to see what they would do
a bill burr here and I thought they did
the right blend of adding things that
I'm not used to seeing billboard do
while keeping the comedy that he's good
at and still feeling like he's not
telling jokes but but conversing yeah
you know yeah and that almost adds to
the to the 80s sci-fi horror
you know vibes that you you know brought
up earlier because like I think of
movies like alien or whatever that have
these diverse casts or you have a couple
you know more comedic or lighter
statured actors get in because you know
that makes the world dynamic you know in
terms of characters or more dynamic
because then I think it does also borrow
from your association just a little bit
they're gonna be aware that people are
yeah yeah but it seems like he was
specifically sought out for this yeah
yeah and then it seemed appropriate like
with the tropes that they do even right
down to the tracker being on the brother
I thought was you know like we've seen
that trope done but it was also
unexpected in the way it was yeah it was
very satisfying and rewarding loved this
episode what did you think of this
episode make sure to comp below and know
what Easter eggs did we possibly not
pick up on you know we like white like I
don't know how to say it Twilight why
drinking anyone you know there's the
creature that was from solo a Star Wars
story and the prison that jon favreau
voice I don't know the name of that
creature the planet that man does
history is that's why like I'm imagining
that is some Star Wars references I
don't know look a game or or an extended
University I don't like what you guys
think of this make sure to leave a
comment below subscribe to the reel
rejects please click that notification
Bella get notified whenever you got our
next Mandalorian reaction now check us
on patreon for all them goodies I like
tennis with a patron today shout out to
our friend one of John's closest friends
Erica Tuesday hi Erica hey Erica it's
been a while since I've seen you I think
the last time I saw you was on my
birthday
a year ago six years ago I miss you
where have you been I miss rolling into
your jacuzzi Eric is also a wonderful
artist and she's been making some little
baby Yoda doodle
really yeah if you go to her and go to
her IG go to the Erika Tuesday Instagram
feed you can see a little baby Yoda
doodle she just made Wow this should do
baby Yoda erotica you know I'm sure if
you paid enough uh yeah it's possible
you know it's a broad world and there's
a market for that Erica you know what to
venture onto next I know that's why you
pledged to our patreon because you're
looking for a career advice mm-hmm much
love to you Erica